papause forcée, ils n'ont rien
peperdu de leur créativité et de
leleur force. Parlant de force,e
paparle de femmes fortes dans mn
rereportage. Entre autres une
arartiste du Cirque du Soleil
s's'est réinventée pendant la
papandémie. Est une chanteuse qi
a a décidé de tout miser  à V V.
♪♪ ♪ ♪♪
- - Las Vegas, la ville du vice,
lala Mecque des enterrements de
vivie de garçon, le royaume des
babars de danseuses et peut-être
l'l'une des capitales du machis.
UnUne image 100 fois renforcée
papar Hollywood.
U Une image qui contraste avec
leles femmes fortes qu'interprèe
lala Québécoise Elyzabeth Diaga
dadans son spectacle "Queens of
RoRock", présenté sur r la stri.
♪♪  ♪  ♪
L L'ex-participante de l'émissn
"L"La voix" s'est installée
enen résidence à T The Mosaic
OnOn The Strip, une salle de
50500 places où elle présente
soson spectacle 5 soirs
papar semaine.
ELELYZABETH DIAGA, chanteuse
etet créatrice de "Queens of Ro"
- - Il y a du monde qui vient
icici pour... pour miser,
popour gambler de l'argent.
MoMoi, pour moi, je suis venue
ici i pour miser, je mise un peu
mama vie, je mise mon âmeme,
jeje mise ma passion.
♪♪ ♪ ♪♪
- - Et le public est au rendez-
vovous pour écouter son hommage
auaux grandes dames du rock,
ququ'interprètete Élyzabeth
avavec un talent indéniable.
- - L'état d'esprit est positif,
leles gens ont hâtete de revenir
àà l la vie, ils ont soif de
spspectacles, ils participent
bebeaucoup, fait que c'est
popositif. Mais moi, j'ai hâte
ququ'arrivent mes Québécois
ququand même, , parce qu'on sait
quque les Québécois, ça met
lele party dans une place!
- - Et si les touristes québécos
sosont peu nombreux à cauause ds
rerestrictions à l la frontière,
leles expatriés de la Belle
PrProvince sont nombreux.
PaParmi eux : Caroline Lauzon.
EtEt mêmeme si on la fait virevr
chchaque soir dans les airs,
elelle est loin d'êtrtre une fee
obobjet. C'est une femme forte
ququi a réussi à faiaire sa plae
icici, mais elle l'avoue,
onon ne peut pas dire que
VeVegas soit une ville
paparticulièrerement feministe.
CACAROLINE LAUZON, artiste Cirqe
dudu Soleil et agente immobilièe
- - C'est Vegas, hein, donc c'et
trtrès s jeu, femme, boire et tt
çaça. Comme tu dis, il y a des
bibillllboards un peu partout, c
dedes femmes presque habillées..
(r(rires)
EuEuh... ouais, c'est un peu...
MaMais c'est ce que les gens
veveulent, c'est ce que les gens
veveulent voir. On leur donne...
onon laisse les gens fumer en
dededans... en autant que les gs
viviennent et dépensent des sou.
- - Au cours de sa carrière,,
elelle a participé à 4 s spectas
dudu Cirque du Soleil, interpréé
3030 personnages et même p parté
auaux Oscars. Mais en mars 2020,
totout s'est arrêtété.
- - Average weekly sales price
wewent up...
- - Elle a alors décidé de
dedevenir courtièrere immobiliè.
EtEt les affaires vont bien,
paparce que dans le désert,
lele marché surchauffe.
- - Le "average sales price" ic,
c'c'était 300 000 l'année passé,
pupuis on est rendu à 5 500 000
enen juste une année.
SiSi tu es un vendeur, tu es trs
heheureux; si tu es un acheteur,
tutu t'en arraches les cheveux.
♪♪  ♪  ♪
- - Le 1 juillet, elle replongea
dadans le spectacle "O",
ququi reprend l'affiche.
MaMais la superwoman entend
êêtrtre courtière l le jour
etet acrobate le soir.
- - Je pense que ça va êtrtre
unune belle transition pour
l'l'après-s-carrièrere, mais vr,
l'l'amour de ma vie, ça va êtrte
lele Cirque du Soleil à j jamai.
♪♪  ♪  ♪
- - Dans cette ville où
leles clichés sexistes sont
omomniprésents se cachent des
fefemmes fortes et talentueuses
ququi n'ont pas peur de se
reretrousser les manches et de e
réréinventer face à l l'adversi.
I Ici Nabi-Alexandre Chartier,
R Radio-Canada, Las Vegas